[موسيقى]
اه انا اعمل اه الكل مش هيك اذا عن الفن
وبعدين هو التجربه الشخصيه وبعدين هنا عرض
سريع
اه
الاعدادي اه كان عندي مدرسه اه
كانت جميله جدا اسلاميه سنه
كنا بناخذ ماده في الوقت اه اسمها التذوق
الفني مش انه احنا اه نعم الفن مش انه
احنا اه نرسم او كذا لا احنا كنا بس ان
تفرج عن اللوحات ونشوفها يبدو ايه يعني زي
ما بيقولوا
المدرسه بالجمله اه فريقه في حياتي
بالكامل
اه عشان كده فكره انتم احيانا مش محتاج
كلام كثير ولا اي حاجه لو انت مركز ممكن
كلمه واحده بس هذا كلها قالت لي ان الفنان
الحقيقي هو اللي بيطلع من الشيء الرخص شيء
ثاني
الفنان الحقيقي هو اللي بيطلع من الشيء
الرس اللي هو يعني حاجه عديده جدا اه شيء
نفيس النهار ده الاحد من كثر ما هي قيمتها
كبيره جدا اه دائما في قبله يقول لك هذه
اللوحه لا تقدر بثمن
الوحده اصلا اللي فينا
فالمهم اه
اشتغلت شويا في الفن وبعدين انا مؤمن
بالفن بصراحه بصفه عامه اه بكل انواعه اه
هو مؤمن ان الفن على مدار الحضارات اللي
فاتت كلها قادر يغير يغير مفهوم الناس غير
وعي الناس اه يخليهم ارضه وهكذا
فكانت عليها فتره اهتميت اه مجال الخط
العربي
وكانت لنا ا دروسا اكاديميه صحيحه
عايز الاسفين اللي
ست سنين ست سنين
اه اول سنه
كان عندي معلم بردو قال لي كل ما فرقت
معينه جدا قال لي انت عشان تكتب الحرب صح
واحد كتبوا مركزه في اللي ممكن
قال لي انت كتب الحرب الحرب صح احتاجت
كتبوا الف مره
وعشان تكتب واحلم
كمان الف مره بالحرف الواحد في الخط
الواحد وعلشان تكتبوا بطريقه راحتك تكتب
كمان الف مره
وكان
الحرب الواحد عشان كتب بطريقه في روح اه
لا يقدر بثمن محتاج ثلاثه الاف
الفكره انها لاقت البارده بين قررت الحاجه
اه اللي احنا محتاجين اه انت عشان تعلم
حاجه جديده محتاج تكررها اكثر من مره
وبعد ان تقيم التكرار ده تقيم التجربه
وبعدين التجاره ثاني وبعدين تعيد التقييم
يمكن يسر بتاع ال التطور ال بالنسبه لي
انا يعني اه فكرتنا كل ما وصل الى مرحله
اه اعيد تقيم كل حاجه اه الطلب تقول لهم
انتم نحقق ثلاثه
اه اولمرت عشان انت مش عارف هذا تعلم ثاني
مره اخرى عشان تنسيق ثلاث مرات تفتكر بدري
رابع مره ما ينفعش تمت اه
كان دائما انساني هو يعني عمل فني اصلا ول
ينعمل الفن دا بملايين الملايين او
بالمليارات الحقيقه ان العمل في النهايه
اللي بيعملها فنانا قويه اه بتلعب على جزء
خطير قوي في حياه الشخص اللي بيشتري العمل
الفنيه الجزيره اسمه غربه الذهني يعني
الفنان ما بيعمل العمل الفني
يفكر ت بحاجه
لما تشوف انت العمل الفني ده حاجه بيطلب
منك احيانا واحنا واحنا وانت في طريق
نجاحك ممكن تبقى طريق
اللي
حاجه تحيات قويه في بعض الناس البصريه
يعني تحديدا اه بيتر معهم او فكره اللوحه
او فكره انه هو يشوف احلامه مكتوبه كل
شويه عشان يفتكر هو اصلا بدلي فيمكن دا
ببساطه جدا اه اهميه العمل الفني اه في كل
بيت اه او اهميه اه نحن ايضا تميم الفن
وهكذا انت يعني احنا حتى لما لما لما شوف
لمحل يصير فيه شك ديني وبعدين شويه وبعدين
ديني وهكذا اه
احنا عملنا
حاجه بسيطه اه بس فيها شويه يعني اه
وركزوا فيها واتمنى انها شكرا
[تصفيق]
بما ان المدرسه بتاعت قالت لي الفن
الحقيقي يصنع من الشيء الراس
هذا ما اكده الكويت
الحقيقه انا من
استرجعها الان
[موسيقى]
ام